on social media what do you guys  consider cheating i'm going to give you  a couple examples  this is fun so guys liking instagram  models bikini pictures i mean that's not  cheating  it's not cheating but it's like why was  that necessary but if you it's not  cheating  but it's just kind of moist why why are  you doing it bro but if you saw like a  male  would you no because i was like why  would i do it but i understand cheating  do you think um  i wouldn't it's like it's okay for the  guys out there that do that like why  yeah exactly  she doesn't see exactly  yeah on the guy's part it's just thirsty  and it's it's a bit moist yeah it's a  bit moist like you shouldn't yeah  there's no point in doing that just look  let's go that's it yeah yeah i think we  all have eyes and we appreciate  beautiful things it's human so if i see  a guy that is pretty and he looks good  and he looks hot even on the street i  mean i'm not gonna be like like on